The next few problems we're going to be talking about shock absorbers
and shock absorbers help keep your car ride smooth even when the road is extra bumpy.
Now, for this problem let's imagine that each of the four wheels on a car each has a shock absorber,
which we're going to model as a single spring with spring constant K.
There are four wheels here, and each one is separated from the body of the car
with one of these springs with spring constant K.
K is equal to 100,000 N/m and if the mass of the car is 2000 kg,
can you tell me what's going to be the displacement Δx,
so how much are these springs going to compress away from their equilibrium position
when we put the mass of the car on those springs.
Give your answer in centimeters here.